I gave you a list of my supplements, which was a lot of items for reference, did you
not comment on them because I shouldn't take them anymore?
Or is it up to me since you concentrated on the most important, which included quite
a few new things?
I wondered if I keep hacking stuff like dim and melatonin and thyroid glandular and turkey
tail, or your mushroom mix, so I'm just a bit confused on what to do with my prior
program, because maybe I should have someone local test me once I have all the new things
gathered to see what I should still take from the old program.
The only thing that I would say that you should take from the old program would be this thyroid
glandular because that is tied to the cancer.
That's your thyroid glandular.
That's not going to test for cancer.
The other things I would just put in the refrigerator and say, you wanted a complete reset
that's what you asked for, so that's what I did.
I just locked in the cancer and tested what is going to be the most important for you, and
the other ones did come up, but thyroid glandular won't come up for cancer anyway, so that's
a completely separate thing, you do that for thyroid, I would keep doing that, but I tested
for it and gave you the data for cancer, so...